comme chaque année à pareille époque la
cour des comptes c'est à dire le
gendarme des deniers publics aligne les
administrations et les établissements
publics qu'elle a pour mission de passer
au crible
cette année chacun en prend pour son
grade cela va de l'éducation nationale
ou ptt en passant par le ministère de la
défense
et même le musée de la ville est
inauguré il ya quelques mois sur ce
dernier exemple voici l'enquète de
véronique auger et dire qu'ils ont
failli là plaisait êtes en panne
d'imagination la direction de la
villette avait fait appel à une société
dite de créativité pour qu'elles
recherchent un nom à cette phase de
cinéma super panoramique
coût de l'opération 41 1350 francs
propositions après études pourquoi pas
boubou irma minouche est déserte double
zéro le nom finalement retenu la géode
n'était pas dans la liste
beaucoup plus grave tout le complexe de
la ville est lancée par valéry giscard
d'estaing en 79 devaient théoriquement
coûté 800 millions de francs le jour de
l'inauguration par françois mitterrand
en mars dernier il avait déjà fallu
débourser 5 milliards et demi cette fois
plus que prévu
non seulement les deux vies étaient
sous-estimés au départ mais les
directions sont tombées les unes après
les autres
chaque nouveau directeur a annulé ce
qu'avait fait l'ancien chaque nouvelle
équipe a voulu lancer des études auprès
de sociétés extérieures
la cour des comptes a recensé 1500
projet sur quatre ans dernière folie
mise en avant par la cour des comptes
l'équipe de la villette a voulu
fabriquer elle-même le premier film
passé à la géode l'eau et les hommes en
raison de la technique jamais utilisé en
europe de la location d'hélicoptères et
d'un sous marin
le tournage a coûté 10 millions et demi
par suite d'erreurs successives seuls
cinq minutes de la copie originale
pouvait être utilisé il a fallu refaire
un autre film coût total de l'opération
24 millions de francs alors la
construction du parc de la villette
valait-elle le coup
pour deux raisons d'abord parce que
c'est un élément de diffusion et de
formation absolument irremplaçables et
puis deuxièmement bien sûr il ya
toujours dans ces grands projets des
erreurs du mois des errements sur le
plan d'aidé des chiffrages même la nasa
se trompera habituellement dans le
rapport de 1 à 5 entre l'estimation du
début et la réalisation par conséquent
je cible que ce qui a été fait là un
vaut le coup et deuxièmement que les
errements son blog de grandes heures
habituelles dans ces grands équipe
dernière remarque de la cour des comptes
sur le musée des sciences
tous les ans chaque français devra
verser 10 francs pour qu'il équilibre
son budget sans tout 550 millions de
francs